tenemos una situación bastante
complicada que si
agarrado al gobierno un bajo reflejo
porque justamente se está cuestionando
mucho la capacidad técnica del equipo
que está gobernando el país líder ahora
pero casting en el país existen muchos
tecnicismos sobre su capacidad se han
visto designaciones básicamente
políticas entre qué técnicas y un
gobierno no solamente se gestiona con
políticos internos con técnicos que
pueden hacer políticas pero que tengamos
contenido técnico entonces es ahí donde
nosotros por ejemplo el artículo pues
que se debieron haber tomado medida de
manera anticipada y no generar una
situación como la que se afronta ahora
donde toda la cadena de producción de
bienes y servicios está con él sobre el
costo normal con la crisis energética y
hay una consecuencia un impacto directo
dedicación 3.6 por ciento de lo que es
la inflación en el país es algo atípico
que hace décadas y obviamente un
malestar por parte de la ciudadanía en
cualquier incremento sustancial
eso ha motivado justamente esta crisis
pero hay que tener en cuenta hay una
suma en otros aspectos como por ejemplo
el caso de los últimos cambiar el
director pero castigo ha vuelto un
secretario general del palacio muy
cercano a él hay otros elementos como
cajas de comunicaciones del presidente
lo cual si no eran más afecta mucho supe
de críticas generales confianza y bueno
embarcar y es una situación que está
pasando la factura básicamente para
inexperiencia que tiene este mandatario
expuso el propio para hermanos y títulos